what's up guys I'm Greg Alba hi I'm John
Humphrey we are about to start a
stranger thing season 3 episode 1 we're
gonna cover the whole season hopefully
none of the videos get blocked worldwide
on YouTube a few of the ones from season
2 did so hopefully everything pans out
ok this time around for YouTube you can
only do reaction highlights a maximum of
10 minutes cut over at our patreon we're
gonna include the full length reaction
stream along since most people have
Netflix you can stream along with us
over at our patreon uncut we are gonna
be uploading an episode reaction one day
at a time so if you guys can subscribe
and more importantly click that
notification bell so you can be notified
when the video is up that would very
much be appreciated a couple of things I
just want to mention really fast Eric
over at nerd cronic he is the one
assembling the stream along and the
reaction highlights for us they do take
quite a while to put together so
neurotic go ahead and follow him you've
seen some of his work for Eamon snow
aqus on the movie trivia Schmo down and
he's just a wonderful wonderful dude
I've had many many many long
conversations with the guy love the hell
out of him and over at our patron like I
said we will be having stream along as
we have stream along for several shows
over there those are haunting of Hill
House John finished the whole first
season Cobra Kai season two Gotham and
then there are several shows will reduce
stream along for them as well as
reaction highlights included and those
are my hero academia just finished all
three seasons attack on titan finish
that final season great stuff John just
finished Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood one punch man and we do
supernatural as well Ilse fine like
Gotham and Black Mirror season 5 a whole
bunch of goodies so check out our
patreon page for all that as well on to
stranger things season 3 episode 1
oh damn we're creating a gateway
very cool Captain Marvel
Russian Russian belly
all right brush Oh dance so they found a
way to get in you know hold her inside
of the world yeah that's cool oh now
that relates so much with Deb kids
making out of my house
don't watch
[Music]
see you tomorrow right wrong
so Lucas and Max are official Steve
[Music]
I just made that just got there that
just opened those people gonna get off
the escalation you know I never question
why everyone stays in Hawkins baby after
season three people is chargeable we
have will be twice
[Music]
Wow
Oh about that I'm so glad we got the
same haircut this season John's mom
behaves exactly
[Music]
cause cat
[Music]
Farrah Fawcett
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm gonna go to the bathroom really
quick I'll be out in five minutes
[Music]
do it
that baby's eyeshadow yeah Livia I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'll make music yeah how
many small businesses close by at least
I think you've got something even
spicier missing mustard on my hamburger
[Music]
it's so hard to be a woman in journalism
nice I can talk to my girlfriend
whenever and wherever I choose oh I'll
tell you enhance the characters you get
them you control for airport give them a
girlfriend cuz girls enhanced guys they
sure you expand
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
your hand away sure they better get
together I only have three seasons left
of will they one day we're gonna make
out
[Music]
Wow
see this will form some like type of
take it so yeah oh do you not wanna
watch this oh my god they're exploding
[Music]
girls always at the pool always said
stools
he's going with she has a kid oh dude I
think he has a girl she just not daebak
I think he really does but I think we're
supposed to think she doesn't know the
rider gets younger every seasons I know
well she's just less fraught everything
[Music]
they're funnier States haha here
[Music]
never mind I get why she's not hopping
on hop oh she's gonna come back is like
so I know she's gonna come back because
he has upside down feature that's how
she's gonna grieve
oh wow
[Music]
[Music]
no girl is that perfect is that so
perfect in your own way in your special
oh no relax is cheesing i'm obviously
perfect injustice
[Music]
Ezra will goes missing it may be dust it
goes aliens subtitles are correct
[Music]
yeah and only that is light on your
vanities it's probably a sleeping
snoring he is asleep in story I mean I
still do it right I mean if I were a
woman not a man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well this was a good return to the show
I'm gonna be going up against the
Russians the Russians if they're not
German they're Russian slightly wrong
era for Germany slightly wrong here for
China I mean I don't know if the
Russians are the bad guys of the season
yet you know they could be misleading in
some direction usually with movies and
shows I got to the poem like all right
Russians tend to be bad guys I guess for
the era and the time they're in based
off setups from the last season this
makes some sense this makes more sense
I like that every season of stranger
things you kind of get the introduction
of how much time has passed or whatever
what everybody's up to this season at
least you have you know Dustin coming
back from his trip or whatever you have
like little things like that to kind of
shake up all their relationships and
stuff you have al back this season so
it's like her and Mike now where Zach
last season Mike was kind of loner II on
his own I was like catching back up that
they take the time to advance the
characters like that I feel like there's
a big boost of positive energy at the
beginning of this season I think what it
was what they're doing right now is
they're settling us into something that
feels like no things are normal you know
and everything in Hawkins has been fine
I mean their prams that they're
experiencing are just real life problems
and not the after-effects necessarily of
what occurred last season it's like okay
the star core ball is but a lot of
people out of business you know things
like that hopper his problem is being a
dad
you know I mean like they explored at
the beginning of season two but that was
still like this is a very secretive
relationship they have no one can know
he has 11 and this one it's just watched
and struggle to be a real dad this time
around and they're more normal
circumstances yeah which is probably my
favorite part of this whole episode I
also really do appreciate that with
Joyce they're not just ignoring
I feel like a lot of shows might take
that route and just let's focus on now
her and hopper getting together but
we're probably gonna experience a lot of
her grieving through the situation of
how happened with Bob which I appreciate
the show is taking the time to
acknowledge or put the effort forth for
something like that too
the one thing I was really appreciating
both having just finished season two and
also going into this episode here is
that they do a really nice job of paying
attention to the little details that
they lay down big or small nothing feels
like it is gone or forgotten because you
really do feel like you're kind of
growing with this situation it's like
the first season you know you've learned
that all this crazy stuff is possible
but I think what helps this keep moving
is that the upside down is like a realm
unto itself whether or not we break
through it I feel like there are
interesting ways to keep that going we
yeah I really liked that
yeah we don't ignore Bob or anything
like that they just bother with those
kinds of character relationships because
it makes those elements ring that much
truer if we just drop hoppers original
family storyline he doesn't have this
relationship with women or something it
might not be as interesting I like that
they bolster the sci-fi with that stuff
having Jonathan and got what's-her-name
Nancy yeah having them like trying to
work at the paper and stuff like that on
the heels of what they did last season
just like the logical conclusions seem
like they make at least some sense and
it makes me look forward to seeing the
characters not just the crazy sci-fi
true I mean yeah we got a lot of
Jonathan this episode yeah we're
definitely seeing with Jonathan's up to
this season I got a lot of what he's
going well or Steve Steve isn't cool
anymore you know Steve is a pretty lame
now uh I wouldn't say that
he's helping kids sneak into r-rated
movies well nothing coolest guy in the
world my opinion of the kid I have
little kids sneaking r-rated movies all
the time that's good you're an example
you're I'm an American Hero
I like that it had more of a human feel
to it instead of focusing a lot on the
supernatural which I feel is important
for a reintroduction into the show it's
relatable because you have
aspects of the jobs and the stress of
choice grieving l and the family aspect
I feel like every girl has that crazy
moment with her father and you can
relate to that so know if you guys could
relate to that but every girl has has
been in a situation like that I feel
like I liked those moments I felt I felt
like it was a strong perception and I
like how kind of Dustin is the loner now
yeah he's the odd man out so to flipp
from last season where we like Mike was
the odd one out poor dusty that girl
does exist she is real yes I hope she
comes in at the very last episode yeah
show shows up and it's like a famous
famous woman Selena Gomez ya know it's
gonna be amazing Williams she's gonna be
like haven't you been getting my
transmissions and this is gonna smash to
black oh yeah happy cool crossword
universes and also with the Billy
character he was like so [ __ ] a
second seat Oh like two is a whole
degree that was borderline unbelievable
to me like wow this guy is oh yeah the
reintroduction to him here they they're
taking an interesting approach it looks
like whatever's going on is somehow
gonna take hold of him and he will be
the host for whatever it is that's just
the vibe I'm getting yeah yeah well we
may see a little more from his
perspective and actually see him I feel
like we see a lot of him from Max's
perspective in season two and so like
maybe this way what kind of you to do
right but at the same time we're even
with this episode sure he's calling
though the little boy lard and lard boy
which is really offensive I didn't feel
like the show was really hammering home
this guy is the biggest dick you've ever
met you know yeah he overcompensates yes
yeah I kind of get that impression too
at the same time I'm just glad the show
is actually we are they've taken this
time to make him feel more charming and
less just jerk you know like that's
that's one of the charms of the show
overall is as it expands you know it
actually gives his characters like that
a little time to charm you and to become
more than just yeah like a one
no you know antagonists but hey we're
busy through this so you know we don't
want to spend too much time talk about
everything
Netflix designer shows to binge and not
to theorize about what's gonna happen in
the next episode but to just quickly
find out over at our patreon page you
could catch the full links to Rima longs
for stranger things as well as all those
other shows much at the top of this
video and I did put out a post for about
our patreon saying if your pledge for
the shout out reward tier and if you
watch stranger things let me know one of
the first people to comment is a man
named Daniel Gallo Cotter he's I don't
think I've told you about him baby
he's a Scottish guy fights with a sword
wears a kilt and a stereotypical as can
be doesn't even know what a computer is
or how he was able to pledge to a
patreon page Thank You Gerard Butler but
like way sexier yeah like 200 times sex
think Mel Gibson Braveheart yeah think
Sean Connery before that Barbara Walters
interview where he said he slaps woman
that is the kind of Scottish man Daniel
Gallagher is but he does slap women
Daniel you've been a part of our patreon
page for I think almost a whole year not
that I remember going off my memory I
think it's ten months at this point so
thank you for being pledge for so long
not many people stay applies longer than
a month and you are part of the 48% that
day so really appreciate it dude I hope
you've enjoyed stranger things and you
lucky son of a B who gets the first
shout out of the first episode of the
stranger things much love to you thank
you Eric for editing down the reaction
highlights for us and putting together
the stream along you guys can subscribe
for the reject nation click that
notification bell keep a look out for
our next episode reaction I think we're
done let's move on